[Musique]
sur france 24 consacrait à ce discours
de vladimir poutine à moscou sur la
place rouge à l'occasion de la
traditionnelle et symbolique parade
militaire du 9 mai qui marque la
victoire sur les nazis le président
russe a placé l'intervention en ukraine
dans la droite ligne de 1945 en
proclamant que son armée combat en
ukraine pour défendre la patrie contre
une menace inacceptable
ce 9 mai célèbre aussi la journée de
l'europe à strasbourg où l'union
européenne a affiché aujourd'hui ses
valeurs de paix et d'unité en opposition
justement à ce discours guerriers de
poutine emmanuel macron a conforté son
soutien à l'ukraine quant à volodimir et
l'ins qui il a affirmé sa détermination
nous avons vaincu nous vaincrons
maintenant a martelé le président
ukrainien juste avant le défilé à moscou
alors que peut-on retenir de ce défilé y
at il eu un avant et un après neuf mais
ce discours de vladimir poutine et il le
reflet de la version poutinienne de
l'histoire y at il finalement deux
visions du monde l'une véhicules et à
moscou l'autre à strasbourg ou encore à
kiev 9 mai le récit historique de
poutine on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés de
thierry wolton bonsoir essayiste
spécialiste des sociétés communistes et
post communiste votre dernier livre
penser le communisme et c'est chez
grasset bienvenue à vous en face de vous
michaël prazan bonsoir écrivain et
documentariste ce soir on pourra
regarder votre documentaire sur france 3
à 21h10 hitler staline le choc des
tyrans bienvenue à vous également adrien
théaux est avec nous bonsoir rédacteur
en chef rédacteur pardon à la revue
conflit hauteur de la france atlantis où
le naufrage de la diplomatie et c'est
aux éditions du cerf bienvenue à vous
également en face de vous donner kataïev
bonsoir vous alors qu'un journaliste
russe vous êtes en résidence à radio
france car vous avez fui la russie après
la fermeture de la chaîne télé donne je
vous en parlerai bienvenue à vous
également nous avons duplex de kiev
bastien renouer notre correspondant
bonsoir bastien
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
d'ailleurs sur les réseaux sociaux les
réseaux sociaux c'est sûr hashtag débat
f24 directs sont tout de suite moscou où
l'on retrouve karine h à bourg karina
bonsoir vous avez suivi ce défilé à
moscou il y avait beaucoup de monde
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé
mais écoutez c'était finalement une
parade militaire assez ordinaire sans
invités de marque 100 invités étrangers
et sans défilé aérien qui était pourtant
très attendu il n'y a pas eu de z
marquée par les les avions chasseurs
dans le ciel moscovite il n'y a pas eu
non plus sept avions dit de l'apocalypse
un sur lequel pendant les différents les
essais de ce week-end avait été très
largement commentée en fait il ya eu au
final peu moins d'hommes et un peu de
monde matériel que les années
précédentes
quant au discours de vladimir poutine
vous l'avez dit pad annonce nouvelle il
l'a simplement une nouvelle fois
justifié son opération spéciale en
ukraine tel qu'il appelle par la menace
selon lui que représenterait l'otan
crois c'est pour le ses frontières et
puis vous savez dans la foule finalement
c'était un avis qui était assez
largement partagé même si beaucoup
disaient regretter les destructions les
morts sur le sol ukrainien et beaucoup
aussi et bien ne souhaitait pas aborder
cette question et notamment la référence
faite à de multiples reprises à
l'allemagne nazie ça n'était pas le lieu
ça n'était pas le moment vous savez le 9
mai c'est quelque chose de sacré pour de
nombreux russes qui est d'ailleurs dans
la foulée et bien ont défilé lors de ces
régiments des immortels avec la photo de
leurs ancêtres anciens combattants dans
les rues de moscou est là aussi vladimir
poutine s'est invitée pour la sixième
fois dans ce défilé lorsqu'il est passé
sur la place rouge avec la photo de son
père vous savez ce défilé au départ
c'est quelque chose de familial de
spontané et qui désormais figure dans le
programme officiel de ces commémorations
qui reçoit d'ailleurs des subventions et
qui est très largement et de façon assez
opportune relayée dans les médias
étatiques merci karina on va tous et
écouter bladimir poutine
l'occident se prépare est ouvertement à
une opération de représailles dans le
donbass et en crimée jusqu'à ixième les
copains kiev
on parlait de possibles armes nucléaires
n'étaient ni à dire rouge
l'otan se rapprochait de notre
territoire
ainsi petit à petit une menace
inadmissible pour nous planait au dessus
de nos frontières on a gagné 2000 wolton
à qu'avez vous pensé de son discours
poutine devait annoncer une victoire
c'est ce qu'on pensait finalement il n'a
pas pu le faire mais il a mis en avant
on voit cette menace inacceptable en
ukraine mais d'abord s'attendait au pire
puisqu'on avait annoncé et plein de
choses en lisant ce 9 mai ça va être
incroyable
finalement c'était nouveau che comme on
dit puisque même les avions n'ont pas pu
voler à fuser météo a causé météo dit on
c'est vrai non non je crois que c'est
vrai quand même la presse cause conclut
que savoir bon bref toujours est il que
ce discours était dans la droite ligne
de ce qu'il a dit depuis le vent le 24
février date de l'invasion de l'ukraine
il le répète depuis en vérité un certain
nombre d'années il s'est fixé comme
objectif de des nazis fier
le cren finalement il arrivera peut-être
à désigner une partie de rennes en tout
cas cette partie qui est à l'est donc
certainement pas tout le territoire donc
c'est en vérité une défaite par rapport
quand même assez objectif primaire
j'entends donc ils s'accrochent à cette
cette fiction pourrait-on dire ça c'est
finalement une section parce que qui
peut croire aujourd'hui que le cren et
nazifié donc il s'accroche à ses
fictions pour justifier son ca cette
guerre maintenant ce qui est intéressant
de savoir à mon avis c'est de savoir
pourquoi cette fiction c'est ça
l'intérêt pourquoi ce récit pourquoi ce
récit à quoi ce récit se rit de combrée
correspond-t-il dans l'imaginaire de
poutine bien sûr mais aussi dans
l'imaginaire des russes parce que de
fait ça fonctionne assez bien puisque
d'après ce que l'on sait et si l'on peut
croire les sondages en tout cas une
bonne partie de 80% dit ou même la
population appuie cette guerre et c'est
bon et cette invasion donc ça veut dire
quelque chose chez les russes denis
quatrième ça veut dire quelque chose
c'est les russes justement ce discours
est ce qu'on peut dire qu'elle est tout
de même à navan 9 mai où après neuf mais
ce n'était pas un tournant
aucun intérêt pour moi parce que
évidemment c'était le défilé sans
victoire c'était comme d'habitude sauf
que les partis de rien était annulé pour
ceux de l'émission mais à mon avis non
parce qu' il existe une autre version en
russie la menace du sabotage
il avait à peur que l'avion ne pouvait
un projet sur la place rouge et pour
poutine c'est dans l'air parce que c'est
dangereux parce c'est pourquoi peut-être
le parti a rien été annulé et qui est
source dix ans on voit ça ou ce que vous
dites là oui c'est les sources de la
russie c'est l'expert qui est dit ça et
je suis sûr que c'est possible c'est
possible parce que les gens ont eu peur
de faire voler la wii et les tubes comme
poutine n'a peur toujours beaucoup vos
sauts bosses ce n'est as
la table avec messieurs mâcon c'est
pourquoi je suis sûr mais c'était comme
d'habitude toujours les discours contre
l'otan toujours les discours à contre
l'occident tôt c'est pourquoi à aucune
intérêt pour moi et rien changé
michel là michaël prazan votre
documentaire sur staline et hitler et
diffusé donc ce soir je le disais avec
cette réécriture de l'histoire par
poutine est ce qu'on est dans la
continuité de la réécriture de
l'histoire pendant la période
stalinienne
c'est un peu plus compliqué que ça c'est
une mémoire déjà celle de la seconde
guerre mondiale qui a été fluctuante
parce que des 45 staline est très
inquiet de la popularité de l'armée
rouge et plus haut vont il va sabrer cet
héritage méthodiquement et d'ailleurs
même sous son règne le 9 mai comme jour
férié va être abolie donc il va y avoir
une sorte de répression qui va s'abattre
sur l'armée rouge immédiatement après la
victoire et la réhabilitation en réalité
va commencer avec le retour de joukovski
quand même le grand héros de l'armée
rouge pendant la guerre qui avait été un
peu comment dire envoyé en exil par
staline tout de suite après et qui va
devenir ministre des armées et à ce
moment là la réhabilitation de l'armée
rouge et de la grande guerre patriotique
va se mettre en marche jusqu'à brejnev
qui va évidemment sacralisé tout ça donc
cette mémoire elle n'est pas non plus
comment dire linéaire elle a été
fluctuante monstrueux mentaliser s
conseille évidemment instruments
parallèles à faire par exemple dans
votre documentaire vous montrer que
staline veut absolument rencontrer
hitler avant justement qu'il passe le
pacte germano-soviétique ensemble alors
que dans l'histoire officielle me
semble-t-il en union soviétique et
ensuite en russie on dit au contraire
que staline n'avait pas d'autre choix
que de le faire bien sûr une réécriture
immédiatement après la guerre et pas
seulement en russie cette réécriture il
faut bien comprendre aussi qu'en
occident et notamment en france le poids
du parti communiste est à très important
donc il ya eu toute une mythologie qui a
été écrite après la guerre comme quoi au
fond staline
savez très bien cette guerre contre
hitler inévitable et qu'il se préparait
à la guerre et que le pacte germano
soviétique était une manoeuvre dilatoire
en réalité c'est totalement faux il a
cru dans ce pacte lorsqu'on se prépare à
la guerre on ne détruit pas
intégralement son armée comme il le
comme staline le fait à partir de
1938 donc oui c'est une mythologie qui a
été installé par le pouvoir soviétique
pendant et puis ensuite après la guerre
il n'empêche quand même que toutes les
familles russes ont payé un tribut à
cette guerre que c'est quelque chose qui
réagit dans les tripes profondément de
tous les russes et il n'y a pas de
hasard a réactivé un certain vocabulaire
le nazisme de génocide même le signe aux
juifs est un peu un non-dit cette
histoire là mais on voit bien qu'il ait
jeté à la figure de part et d'autre dans
ce conflit aussi bien du côté russe que
du côté ukrainien
je vous fait réagir donc tout de suite
adrien de zoua ce défilé vous quatre
spécialistes d un peu de défense se
défiler de justement c'est un peu
l'occasion de faire défiler les armes
puissantes de la russie en tout cas
c'est comme ça aussi qu'on le comte
présente avec ce contexte même de faé de
l'armée russe sur le terrain en ukraine
dont il y avait un paradoxe là on a vu
tout de même un sergueï choïgou en tête
du défilé il y avait longtemps qu'on
l'avait pas vu le ministre de la défense
oui il ya une prouesse a organisé un
immense défilé alors qu'on engage
quasiment la totalité de ses forces sur
le terrain dans un combat très difficile
en ukraine vous l'avez souligné l'armée
russe est en grande difficulté
clairement elle piétine son offensive
même dans le donbass elle est très lente
elle doit s'appuyer sur une artillerie
qui détruit tout sur son passage et donc
dans ce cadre là à faire défiler quand
même tout ce beau monde à moscou c'est
pas forcément évident je pense qu'on
allait chercher les marins et les
aviateurs mais les avions eux ne sont
pas disponibles c'est pour ça à mon avis
qui n'était pas présent c'est qu'ils
sont en alerte où ils sont engagés tout
simplement dans le ciel ukrainien voilà
pour le reste pour la mémoire de la
guerre je voulais juste réagir sur une
petite chose sur vladimir poutine qui
qui lui même en fête a connu faut pas
l'oublier
le siège de leningrad et dont on a parlé
de son père qui était
affiché dans le grand défilé des anciens
qu'on attend donc pour pour eux pour
poutine c'est aussi une affaire
personnelle ce n'est fait mais ce qu'ils
foutent ils ne peut plus avoir connu le
siège est ingrate pour la simple raison
qu'il est en 52 excusez mon temps parce
que je vois cela je vous l'accordé
volontiers en tout cas en tout cas ses
parents probablement sa
famille il en a la mémoire bien à l'âme
et moi on s'est surtout de vous dire ça
parce que vous avez raison la belle-mère
d'ailleurs de cette ville pendant
longtemps donc effectivement ça n a pas
été mérité je vais rebondir
bref il était allé vers une page où est
le
maître d'école pour vous avez raison
mais pour rebondir justement sur ce que
disait michael prazan sur serait ce que
disait staline est ce qui était écrit
effectivement dans le récit soviétique
la bannière poutine présente son
opération spéciale dans ce discours en
disant finalement que c'était la seule
décision possible pour lui une décision
difficile mais il n'avait pas le choix
on en fait un parallèle un peu avec ce
que staline avait dit à l'époque du
pacte germano-soviétique donc ce qui a
été dit est tout à fait juste ce pacte
germano soviétique a été voulu par les
deux dictateurs sans aucun doute staline
était même prêt à le prolonger et
d'ailleurs tallinn savez et je suppose
que le film qu'on verra on verra ce soir
le montre savait que l'invasion aurait
lieu le 21 juin 1941 il y avait à peu
près 80 information différente de
différents endroits qui lui avaient
donné l'heure le date il n'y a pas que
jusqu'au dernier moment 1 en disant
c'est pas possible qu'il fasse ça parce
que ce pack nous est tellement
profitable à l'un et à l'autre qui
comprenait pas que hitler il dans son
idéologie avait l'intention d'envahir la
rue d'union soviétique bon voilà donc
donc tout ce qui a été monté après est
ce qui a été dit et est juste tout ce
qui a été monté à préfère la
glorification de l'armée rouge le
martyre du pape le russe qu'il faut pas
oublier le peuple parce que je veux dire
il ya 27 millions à 20,8 millions de
morts et y à peu près 12 on sait pas
exactement 12 à 15 millions de morts de
l'armée rouge non tout ça a été si vous
voulez a servi à gommer cette histoire
plus idéologiquement évidemment avec les
partis communistes dans le reste du
monde qui ont servi aussi à ça qu'on
couvert cette affaire
cette façon là voilà on va écouter vos
un dealer et là ce qui est le président
ukrainien qui a pris la parole ce matin
avant justement le défilé à moscou et au
lendemain d'ailleurs d'un discours qu'il
a prononcé devant les immeubles éventrés
et calcinée de borodianka au nord de
kiev on écoute
aujourd'hui nous célébrons la victoire
sur le nazisme et nous ne céderons à
personne le moindre morceau de notre
histoire nous sommes fiers de nos
ancêtres qui avec d'autres nations de la
coalition antihitlérienne ont vaincu le
nazisme et nous ne permettrons à
personne de s'annexer cette victoire
nous ne permettrons pas qu'elles soient
appropriés
bastien aux nouilles vous êtes à kiev il
y as télescopage finalement entre de ces
deux discours et linski d'à côté on
vient de le voir vladimir poutine de
l'autre à kiev finalement on a plus
écoutés et l'inscrit j'imagine plutôt
que poutine
tout à fait oui les habitants kiev ont
apporté assez peu d'intérêt au final à
l'intervention de la dhimmitude poutine
alors évidemment ici tout le monde se
demandait s'il allait annoncer de
nouvelles frappes si l'allaitement
annoncé une guerre totale s'il allait
annoncer une mobilisation générale en
russie étant donné que ça n'a pas été le
cas et bien les ukrainiens n'ont pas
vraiment suivi le discours c'est un
discours de propagande la rhétorique de
poutine ils l'ont suffisamment entendu
distille avant le début de cette guerre
et depuis qu'elle a commencé au mois de
février dernier donc eh bien cela les
intéressés au final assez peu et ils ont
préféré regarder cette vidéo de volodine
un raset lenski cette vidéo qu'il a en
réalité enregistré hier matin nous
sommes passés à côté de la place maïdan
d'ailleurs au moment où il l'enregistré
nous avons vu toutes les rues qui
étaient complètement bloquées pour
pouvoir réussir à faire cette vidéo
extrêmement cinématiques un d'ailleurs
qui est le signe d'une d'une différence
totale de communication entre les deux
hommes on voit vladimir poutine derrière
son pupitre entouré par les militaires
et volodymyr zelensky bien marchant
seule dans les rues de kiev une vidéo
extrêmement cinématiques qui rappelle le
passé d'acteur d'ailleurs du président
ukrainien et qui est beaucoup plus bien
qui incite les ukrainiens vouloir se
défendre à vouloir continuer le combat
il le disait il y aura bientôt deux
jours de la victoire en ukraine le jour
de la victoire contre les nazis et le
jour de la victoire contre la russie
alors que bien bientôt la russie ne
pourra plus célébré deux journées de la
victoire c'est ce que disait volodymyr
zelensky alors les habitants de kiev le
bien préfère essayer de revenir à une
vie normale et c'est de voir les choses
de manière plus positivement ils sont
dans les rues ils se baladent ils vont
au restaurant il retourne travailler il
essaie d'oublier qu'il ya la guerre
autour d'eux mais c'est quand même
extrêmement difficile puisque plusieurs
fois par jour il ya quand même ces
alertes aux bombardements qui
retentissent dans la capitale et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que je suis en ce
moment dans un bunker dans le parking
souterrain de l'hôtel où nous résidons
ici l'équipe de france 24 à kiev
puisqu'il ya en ce moment une alerte aux
bombardements en ukraine comme cela
arrive très régulièrement plusieurs fois
par jour plusieurs fois par nuit est
donc difficile malgré tout pour les
habitants de qui avait bien d'oublier la
guerre qui fait rage dans l'est du pays
mais c'est le retour à la réalité bien
sûr en ukraine sur le terrain michaël
prazan est ce que l'histoire est une
arme de combat devenu une arme politique
poutine a évoqué le cuirassé potemkine
j'ai entendu zelensky évoque les morts
l'ukrainien ça devient une arme
politique finalement histoire dure ça
l'a toujours été et en fait c'est
davantage même que ça c'est quand même
un contentieux finalement jamais réglé
là disons le différend entre
la russie soviétique et l'ukraine et je
pense surtout à l'ukraine occidentale
est un contentieux qui a alimenté des
propagandes en réalité de part et
d'autre et qui a été un peu atomiser par
la chape de plomb de l'union soviétique
mais à partir du moment où l'union
soviétique disparaît et bien tout est
réactivée et d'ailleurs en fait on voit
bien comment après la révolution orange
par exemple en 2004 le président
iouchtchenko arrivé au pouvoir c'est
vrai à donner des gages à la galicie à
l'ukraine occidentale à une forme de
mémoire pro-nazi de cette région et
c'est à partir de là que simultanément
s'est mise en branle
d'abord à bas bruit et puis à la montée
en puissance une propagande russe qui
nazifié les ukrainiens et qui ne les
nazis fia sans voir ce qui se passait à
l'intérieur de l'ukraine un petit
miracle a eu lieu au cours de ces dix
dernières années en termes de
démocratisation tout n'est pas fait un
bien sûr il reste encore beaucoup de
travail notamment qui concerne la
corruption mais il ya une vraie
unification du pays que poutine n'a pas
voulu voir et n'a pas vu et du je pense
d'ailleurs il en a été surpris dans le
bon basque c'est quand même un comble
que de dire qu'on va des nazis fielleux
dont base qui est quand même une
province pro russe ou russophone par
excellence donc il ya plein de
contradictions là dedans mais qui
correspond aussi aux contradictions de
cette région très compliqué
anthony ktf justement sur cette
propagande de vladimir poutine d'après
ce que j'ai lu depuis 2014 et une loi en
russie qui criminalisent la diffusion de
fausse information
donc il ya une ligne qu'il faut suivre
maintenant en russie dans la russie de
poutine sinon on est condamné oui il
nous est arrivé encore il ne veut pas
utiliser juste l'émeut guère c'est
pourquoi j'ai déjà quitté la russie
parce que c'est impossible d'être un
journaliste indépendant on ne peut pas
utiliser juste le mot guerre mais je
voudrais dit que oui c'est vrai il y a
les différences entre deux chefs d'état
c'est le style à wadi nos alliances qui
sait le président de nos jours de demain
et vadimir poutine est toujours le
présidente du passé parce que le passé
l'histoire c'est tout qui reste pour
poutine
c'est pourquoi le 9 mai c'est tout qui
reste pour poutine pour rassembler les
gens parce que se l'est faite à
patriotique mais a il a déjà à
d'explorer
d'exproprier se traite pour lui même
c'est pas aujourd'hui c'est pas la fête
nationale c'est la fête de poutine alain
19 peut-être là-dessus poutine vous
montrer finalement que la russie est
toujours du bon côté de l'histoire je
pense surtout qui veut montrer que la
russie reste un empire et que donc
l'ukraine dans ce cadre-là fait partie
de l' empire néo soviétique en tout cas
c'est à dire que pour poutine l'union
soviétique n'est pas du passé c'est
encore quelque chose de présent il veut
continuer finalement c'est cette grande
russie en fait qui englobe et petits
pays frère quand la biélorussie comme la
moldavie comme plein d'autres pays comme
l'ukraine
maintenant il se confronte à la destinée
de poudenx pire quand on disait du rozel
disait que tout empire périra c'est à
dire que plus un empire s'étend plus
élargie et plus il s'affaiblit aussi
c'est bien ce qu'on voit actuellement en
ukraine ses pieds d'argile ce régime
immortel thierry wolton ce régiment para
dont immortel dont on a parlé sont ces
millions de russes on a vu des images
impressionnantes d'ailleurs pendant
cette parade à travers le pays ils
brandissent des portraits de leurs
ancêtres qui ont participé à la grande
guerre patriotique pour rendre hommage à
ces 26 millions finalement au départ
c'était une initiative de la société
civile récupéré par vladimir poutine oui
c'est ça bien sûr contrairement à quand
on voit ces images assez impressionnante
d'autant plus quand même que le popeye
comme j'étais leur a excessivement
souffert de cette guerre donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui sort de de
son arme si je pourrais dire bon donc
maintenant l'utilisation de cette cette
histoire instrumentalisation cette
histoire par poutine est évidente et
hélas notre journaliste russe a été là
bien dit dans le sens où ça fait 20 ans
qu'elle est de boire plus de 20 ans qui
est au pouvoir désormais la russie va
très très très mal économiquement
socialement
démocratiquement bon tout va très mal et
donc si vous voulez comme souvent
d'ailleurs dans un pays est dans une
histoire c'est classique on
instrumentalise le moment le plus
glorieux de l'histoire pour essayer de
rassembler comme on a dit le peuple
autour au nom du patriotisme et pour
faire oublier son impéritie et et
surtout son incapacité à faire que cette
soupe est très riche n'oublions pas que
la russie est très riche avec une idée
des matières premières gigantesque donc
après 20 ans de pouvoir qui sont dans
une situation comme ça au niveau du pnb
jo du pib je crois qu'il est grosso modo
dans les cent quarantième pays du monde
ce qui est donc rien donc ça veut dire
qu'en matière de
l'espagne la russie levadiakos titre on
était toujours
équivalent aux
aveux d'accord ça vu que tout poutine
est toujours en tournée par les gars tu
m'aimes gart fsb toujours les mêmes gens
à chaque année et alors ça y est ça peut
toujours de l'édifice le défilé pareil
toujours chacun des soucis donc c'est
quoi une permanence dans la continuité
de susan hill a récupéré le défilé des
civils et la route paierait pour
lui-même sapeurs sa peur que vient d
encore déçu ni la et dont on parle et si
c est aussi la marque si vous voulez de
son impopularité quelque part parce que
si alors évidemment chaque dictateur a
toujours peur ça c'est clair ça isole
bon le complexe occident etc mais quand
même il a une peur bleue d'un attentat
et peut-être que effectivement
l'annulation du défilé
aérien en est là qu j'en sais rien ça
mais toujours ici ça montre quand même
qu' il n'est pas si populaire qu'on
pourrait le penser et qu'il sait bien
que thierry d'occasion bas en sera faite
de ceux de liquider si je mets quelques
temps vous êtes d'accord avec ça parce
qu'on voit tout même dans les chiffres
qu'il est populaire vladimir poutine et
que cette propagande je dirais prend il
a réussi quelque chose qui avait réussi
staline au fond il a réussi à imposer
l'idée que la russie c'est lui et que à
partir du moment où il est attaqué c'est
toute la russie qui attaquait et c'est
malheureusement un ressort qui
fonctionne auprès de la population russe
qu'est ce qu'on comprend aujourd'hui
rétrospectivement par rapport à ce qui
vient d'être dit sur la question l'an
pire on pourrait même remonter à l'
empire russe des z'arts c'est qu'au fond
comment considéré t-il l'ukraine
voilà d'accord pour disons un semblant
de démocratie pourvu que les ukrainiens
élisent un gouvernement qui soit pro
russe totalement affidés à la russie à
poutine à partir du moment où les rues
où les ukrainiens faisait un autre choix
eh bien on comprend au fond que c'était
presque inévitablement le conflit voire
la guerre c'est ça qui se passe
aujourd'hui et c'est ça le pardon le
pari bhl double pari perdu de poutine au
fond double pari perdu vous dit bastien
renouil vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit ce que vient de dire
michael prazan cette volonté finalement
de se rapprocher de l'europe de
l'ukraine a effectivement entraîner ce
cet énervement de vladimir poutine pour
être pour utiliser un euphémisme
tout à fait oui et l'ukraine qui demande
une entrée accélérée dans l'union
européenne alors ce n'est pas ça qui va
permettre d'apporter des solutions sur
le court terme pour gagner contre la
russie mais cela montre une volonté sur
le long terme et bien oui de lui tourner
le dos et de s'intégrer plus tôt à
l'ouest au lieu de s'intégrer à l'est
comme lady mire poutine n'espérait dans
le passé alors en revanche ce qui va
pouvoir apporter des solutions à la
lumière alinsky et à l'ukraine et bien
ce sont les embargos ce sont les
pressions économiques sur la russie ce
sont les aides militaires alors de plus
en plus des militaires arrivent ici en
ukraine pour les embargos bien le g7 a
pris des décisions en revanche vous
l'avez vu aujourd'hui l'union européenne
et bien peine à tomber d'accord
notamment sur un embargo sur le pétrole
est là cela pose énormément de problèmes
ici en ukraine on s'inquiète et bien que
les revenus que récupère la russie du
pétrole continuent à alimenter la guerre
et permettent à vladimir poutine tout
simplement de continuer à attaquer
d'ukraine et peut-être un jour de
l'emporter ici justement parce que ce
même 9 mai emmanuel macron a fait un
discours à strasbourg à l'occasion de la
journée de l'europe un discours dans
lequel il dit qu'il soutient vient sur
l'ukraine que l'europe soutient
l'ukraine on va l'écouter le président
français
nous oeuvrons en européen
pour la préservation de la souveraineté
et de l'intégrité territoriale de
l'ukraine pour le retour de la paix sur
notre continent
il n'appartient qu'à l'ukraine de
définir les conditions des négociations
avec la russie
mais notre devoir est d'être à ses côtés
pour obtenir le cessez le feu puis bâtir
la paix
puis nous serons là pour reconstruire
l'ukraine en europe et un adrien qu'est
ce que peut faire de plus l'europe
à mon avis pas grand chose
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron a parlé d'une
grande confédération en fait qui
engloberait tous ces pays qui sont en
périphérie de l'union européenne et même
il a parlé du royaume uni qui a quitté
l'union européenne il ya déjà quelques
années
à mon avis le cessez le feu ça ne vous
convainc pas mais le cessez le feu pour
revenir à la question et cessez le feu
c'est la priorité à mon lien c'est à
dire que la actuellement tout on parle
de guerre on voit les etats-unis qui
sont quand même très offensif et qui
semble-t-il ont intérêt à ce que
l'ukraine se défendent jusqu'au dernier
rue craignant comme on dit quoi qu'il en
coûte alors que l'intérêt de l'union de
l'europe à mon sens c'est de faire une
paix quitte à geler en fait la ligne de
conflits exactement comme s'ils
s'étaient passés en 2014 et ensuite
essayer de reconstruire de rebâtir un
processus pour naples et le processus de
minsk où on aurait un accord entre
ukrainiens et russes dans la durée mais
quelles sont les chances aujourd'hui
finalement qui est un cessez-le-feu ou
même d'un dialogue baal sont elles sont
elles sont à mon avis très digne très
limité et un mail en même temps on sent
bien que les ukrainiens ne parviendront
pas à reconquérir le dombass et la
crimée que les russes ne parviendrons
pas non plus à envahir toute l'ukraine
et à vaincre l'armée ukrainienne parce
qu'elle est tellement soutenu par les
états unis qu'on la sent quasiment
invincible donc un moment donné on se
retrouve un peu dans une forme de match
nul il va falloir siffler la fin de la
partie et quel présent
oui il ya en fait moi ça me rappelle une
phrase qui a eu hitler en 42 43 enfants
au tournant de la guerre on leningrad on
ne négocie pas quand on est en position
de faiblesse et je crois que en tout cas
poutine assume cette citation d'une
certaine manière donc c'est pour ça
qu'on avait au fond une célébration sur
la place rouge un peu à minima il n'a
rien à proposer il n'a pas
déclenchement d'une guerre officielle a
déclaré et il n'a pas de victoire à
célébrer donc pour l'instant je crois
que les négociations sont gelées
oui il vérifié de c'est une position
angélique de penser qu'il va pouvoir
cesser le feu et c'est l'heure qu'il est
c'est impossible de dire à mon avis est
bon je suis pas sûr qu'il faille le
souhaitez mais ça c'est autre chose je
suis pas là je suis pas je suis pas de
militaires et et je ne suis pas en train
de
bien sûr que tous et c'est souhaitable
ça dépend dans quelle condition donc
c'est ça que je veux dire
dans les conditions ne sont pas réunies
actuellement est de toute façon je ne
pense pas que des ukrainiens parce que
c'est quand même eux qui sont les
premiers concernés excusez moi de vous
le dire nous regarde ça du côté de paris
de l'europe etc je ne pense pas que les
ukrainiens sont prêts à mettre les armes
de de se défaire de leurs armes et que
même si éventuellement il y avait un
accord qui se faisait sur une scission
ce qui est l'objectif aujourd'hui à mon
avis de de la nuit à poutine sur une
scission d'une partie de l'est ukrainien
la paix ne sera pas forcément assuré
parce qu'il y aura toujours des
résistances y aura toujours des
escarmouches et ça fera un abcès de
fixation terrible qui restera mon avis
pendant un certain temps sur l'europe
est une question de pourriture si on
pourrait dire délicate à fait d'accord
vous qui êtes russe oui cessez le feu en
vue pour l'instant moi je pense que mon
insistance opérations entre les 8 mai et
9 mai et c'est une séparation
idéologique c'est pas aller question des
horaires parce que 8 mai c'est pour
l'europe et le crème et la partie de
l'europe la russie pour l'instant c'est
le passé ce 9 mai mais jusque là nous
sommes changé le net
je suis sûr que la russie aussi les
parties de l'europe c'est pourquoi cette
guerre c'est guérin de poutine contre
les roux ceci parce que on a choisi le
chemin inverse peine déjà ancien mais il
ya des siècles c'est pourquoi si c'est
possible je voudrais citer
barisien le déserteur et je voudrais se
dresser à monsieur poutine si c'est
possible
si les paroles de bari sia s'il faut
donner le sang allait donner le vôtre
vous êtes bons apôtres à monsieur le
président je voudrais se dresser sa
parole à monsieur poutine
déserteur c'est une chanson de boris
vian michaël prazan or justement parlez
là vous parlez de l'europe à l'instant
de nika tf doit vous faire rebondir là
dessus la russie enfin l'europe sera
définitivement une europe sur la russie
définitivement
non
aujourd'hui j'ai mal par la russie oui
oui marc est bon et il voit là c'est on
est d'un bout à l'autre du continent il
ya effectivement cet espace européen qui
somme toute est assez nouveau enfin il
faut pas non plus est est à mon avis
beaucoup reste à faire et d'une certaine
manière il ya un aveu de faiblesse dans
le discours du président macron de ce
point de vue là on a de belles paroles
de belles pétition de principe mais ce
sera quand même très très difficilement
réalisable ce qu'il propose donc on est
dans une wii sur la suppression du droit
de veto enfin il faudrait que tous les
pays soient d'accord ça va prendre
beaucoup de temps et si tant est que ce
soit possible donc et voilà on est dans
une commande hier dans une une europe
qui s'affirme mais qui n'est pas
terminée et de l'autre côté
effectivement on a ce plus grand pays du
monde qui est en mal de puissance et qui
veut faire valoir sa puissance à quel
prix c'est la grande question de l'issue
de cette guerre c'est parce que voilà la
menace des armes nucléaires bon au fond
personne ne dise on la rejette d'un
revers de la main on sait que dans une
circonstance quelle qu'elle soit elle
est une possibilité elle est
envisageable donc oui pour l'instant la
menace est claire intégré disons la
russie à l'union européenne me semble un
doux rêve pour l'instant attiré voile
tombe justement vous êtes aussi
l'historien de ce plateau et c'était la
maison commune européenne de gorbatchev
donc cette idée là est enterré le
faisait pour un intérêt financier il
faut quand même se rendre compte de ça
parce qu'il était mené la russie est ce
que c'est vraiment pas alors elle a fait
partie du conseil de l'europe cela je
sais bien ce sont bien bien sûr alors ça
se discute avec le général de bozizé de
l'atlantique à l'oural n'est ce pas
l'oral donc et en elle
la chaîne montagneuse qui est super qui
supplie qui divise le continent européen
si on peut dire le continent asiatique
donc bon moi j'ai jamais été j'ai jamais
été un partisan de cette politique dans
le sens où je pense que c'était un doux
m occidentale de penser que la russie
pouvait la russie post-soviétique
j'entends pouvait accepter certaines
conditions démocratiques et on l'a vu
c'est en vérité qui s'appelle c'est pas
le cas puisque la guerre actuellement
c'est dû au fait que l'ukraine avait des
tentes as des tentations démocratique
que ça c'était insupportable c'est pas
la menace de l'otan qui en vérité poussé
poutine à faire cette guerre c'est
simplement éventuellement la le le côté
des teintes de comme on dit je sais pas
te de
et d'emprise que ça peut avoir sur le
sourire sur le reste de mpm sur son
propre pays qui a poussé poutine à faire
ça donc donc c'est certain qu'on se
retrouve avec une europe des démocraties
contre finalement un autocrate
bureaucratie ceci dit je voudrais dire
quand une chose qui me paraît très
importante aujourd'hui et moi ça me fait
quelque chose qui me turlupine depuis un
certain temps puisque j'ai tellement
travaillé sur cette histoire il comme un
incroyable je dis bien incroyable que
les occidentaux se réveille aujourd'hui
face à poutine alors que tout était
éventuellement possibles et connues
contenu du personnage et continue de
l'histoire qui n'a pas été soldés donc
de toute façon aujourd'hui odiah quelle
horreur quel personnage épouvantable on
a quand même reçu les tapis rouge on l'a
on l'a reçu à
dire j'ai paniqué et j'ai pas dit qu'il
fallait pas dialoguer je ne suis pas me
faites pas dire ce que je ne dis pas je
lis qu'il fallait être aguerri il
fallait être et avoir une petite lumière
qui s'allume et et non pas lui dérouler
le tapis rouge comme ça souvent été fait
voilà bastien renouil sur justement
cette question européenne kiev rêverait
ou pas de rentrer dans cette communauté
politique européenne dont a parlé
emmanuel macron alors qu'on sait que
dans le fond à leur entrée dans l'union
européenne
est bien le président volodymyr saelens
qui ne s'est pas encore prononcée 1
depuis le discours d' emmanuel macron
mais il a fort à parier que ce serait
une première étape pour eux on sait les
négociations pour pouvoir entrer dans
l'union européenne sont longues cela
prend plusieurs années voire des
décennies parfois donc ce serait
probablement un premier pas mais c'est
ce que je vous disais précédemment au
final ce qui intéresse le le président
ukrainien dans un premier temps bien
c'est de tourner le dos à la russie ça
c'est sur le long terme le ses ambitions
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne mais sur
le court terme l'objectif c'est de
réussir à résister réussira à s'en
sortir peut-être même à réussir à
récupérer les zones qui ont été
conquises par la russie le dombass la
crimée et pour cela et bien ce n'est pas
l'union européenne qui va pouvoir tout
changé ce sont les états unis ce sont
les européens c'est le g7 par les
pressions économiques par les livraisons
d'armes mais l'intégration au sein de
l'union européenne et bien au final ce
n'est pas ce qui va changer la vie des
ukrainiens dans les prochains mois dans
les prochaines années immédiatement
immédiat adrien desk effectivement il ya
un risque de contagion on parle beaucoup
des risques de contagion de ce conflit
en transnistrie et puis est ce que fit
tellement cette question de
l'utilisation d'armes nucléaires
tactiques en ukraine or poutine reste
d'actualité c'est évidemment des risques
qu'il faut prendre en compte quand on
quand on regarde la situation en ukraine
il faut tout envisager y compris le pire
donc une déstabilisation en moldavie
tout à fait possible pour moi elle n'est
pas immédiate enfin le soir on en a
beaucoup parlé il ya quinze jours elle
semble un petit peu maintenant passée de
mode pour le nucléaire tactique c'est
une possibilité mais en même temps la
partie là où il ya les combats est très
dense d'un point de vue population il ya
un maillage de ville très très serré
donc ça ferait des dégâts même
tactiquement une petite bombe nucléaire
ça ferait quand même des dégâts
absolument extraordinaire donc mon bon
c'est une possibilité mais pour
l'instant je n'y crois pas trop pour le
pour l'europe je voulais juste souligner
quelque chose sur l' empire parce que on
parle évidemment de l'empiré russe qui a
voulu s'étendre mais l'union européenne
aussi veut s'étendre est en fait plus
elle s'étend et plus elle s'affaiblit y
aussi ce qu'a voulu dire emmanuel macron
à mon avis quand il a relégué aux
calendes grecques l'entrée de l'ukraine
dans l'union européenne parce que et en
même temps en parlant d'une renforcement
d'un saut fédéral pour une europe
souveraine c'est-à-dire que soit on
élargit mais dans ce cas là on reste une
espèce de confédération à plage soit au
contraire et c'est un peu peut-être
l'idée du général de gaulle aussi avec
avec le royaume uni quand il a dit non à
l'entrée d'union de le du royaume uni
dans dans la communauté européenne c'est
de renforcer de faire un noyau beaucoup
plus dur ty dennis k taille à fait juste
un mot encore sur ce risque de cons dion
vous pensez vous avec votre réseau enfin
qu' à risque de contagion en
transnistrie justement moldavie de ce
conflit oui c'est possible mais je ne
crois pas à la menace nucléaire parce
que aujourd'hui pas de déclaration de la
guerre mondiale pas de mobilisation
générale je pense que la russie est
faible pour l'instant et poutine et il
faut il faut gagner a le temps pour
poutine c'est pourquoi pas de risque de
nucléaire mais oui les conflits un
commun transmis ce tri oui il existe là
risque existe michaël prazan du coup
d'autres fédérations européennes d'y
intégrer la moldavie je suis moi je
dirais enfin je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec ce qui vient d'être
dit mais je pense que ce que n'a pas
comment dire
ce que n'a pas digéré poutine c'est pas
la moldavie c'est les pays baltes parce
que les pays baltes bon déjà il
considère que ça fait partie de l'empiré
russe et cetera bon et surtout il la
russie a joué dans les pays baltes
qu'elle a joués en ukraine c'est à dire
une forme d'irrédentisme en déplaçant
savez la solution de régler les conflits
pour la russie c'est les déplacements de
population on déplace des régions
entières on déplace des ukrainiens
supposément nationalistes on les envoie
en russie on prend des populations russe
qu'on implante en ukraine
ça a été fait dans les pays baltes donc
on a aussi la même situation avec des
populations russophones des populations
qui sont affiliés à moscou qui adore
poutine etc et qui sont surtout pour les
lettons bien sûr surtout pour les
lettons et c'est évidemment des zones de
déstabilisation à dessein qui ont été
dessinés dans ces endroits là et le fait
que les pays-bas tête et est intégré à
l'union européenne c'est à dire que la
russie perde la main sur ces territoires
là c'est quelque chose qui est très très
difficile à accepter pour la russie et
pour poutine en particulier donc je
crois que alors évidemment si poutine
joue ce qu'il a joués en ukraine dans
les pays bas tu là c'est une tout autre
histoire parce qu on est avec l'union
européenne et avec le temps donc là
effectivement il y aurait une ride par
exemple pour l'instant il n'a pas
franchi cette ligne rouge thierry wolton
peut-être une réaction sur ce qu'a dit
adrien des oies sur effectivement on
élargit cette europe est ce que
finalement on l'affaiblît aussi mais je
pense enfin si on veut être réaliste de
fait je crois que nous elle subit non
lentement mais à mon avis sûrement une
europe à deux vitesses je pense que
c'est ce qu'elle rêvait qui va se passer
et un certain temps alors si c'est
compliqué à mettre en place parce que il
faut défaire ce qui a été fait un bond
et +27 donc une espèce de noyau dur je
dirais de l'europe pas forcément sur les
six camps cocon concret l'europe mais un
peu plus large bien sûr et puis autour
de autour de ça des pays qui serait
intégrée à ce système a mon avis c mais
c'est ce que ceux dont joue pas ses 20
ans ce
matin en europe à plusieurs vitesses oui
plusieurs vitesses matin ça restera
quand même un continent ensemble où il y
aura alors pas forcément une politique
commune ça je sais pas regardez division
qui se passe avec la main avec la
pologne avec la avec la hongrie c'est
déjà très difficile à tenir ça parce que
les différences et
il faut l'élargir y compris dans les
communes puis mai - mais moins avec une
volonté d'une politique forcément toute
commune par rapport à des objectifs
toujours commun y aura peut-être des
différences dans les objectifs je ne
sais pas à cesser la politique fiction
j'entends bien mais telle qu'elle est là
cette europe et en plus si on veut
encore l'élargir ça devient des très
difficile à d'ailleurs il et puis les
questions d'ailleurs je vous suis bien
que madame la présidente a dit qu' il
est question de ne plus avoir le pal
united ou du real
aujourd'hui quelque à vue réforme est
donc plus l'unanimité sur sur les
grandes ceux des grandes lignes d'idéal
a dit et puis c'est très simple demande
de décision à l'unanimité l'une l'accès
à des décisions à la majorité
une conclusion michaël prazan puisqu'on
va attiser votre documentaire de même
qu'ils paraissent à 21h justement hitler
staline le choc des tyrans vladimir
poutine je dirais qu'elle serait la
prochaine utilisation de l'histoire pour
poutine l'a a je pense que la grande
guerre patriotique est un patrimoine
dans l'inépuisable on peut puiser tout
ce qu'on y veut est toujours en faveur
des dirigeants russes et puis de la
population russe au sens le plus large
donc ya pas de raison qu il abandonne ce
filon et mais ce qui est très curieux
aussi enfin bon il ya aussi parce que ce
qui intéresse c'est intéressant ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui quand on a
baissé de ton de part et d'autre j'ai
l'impression alors est ce à dessein est
une stratégie de la part de même si
évidemment on rebondit quand même sur un
discours de propagande presque hitlérien
c'est à dire on ne sait pas nous qui
vous avons attaqué c'est vous qui nous
avez attaqué donc la guerre en ukraine
et en quelque sorte une guerre
préventive et c'était le grand truc
aussi quand même de l'invasion
hitlériennes
à partir du 22 juin 41 reprises les
américains d'ailleurs mais tout ça a
laissé un peu si j'ai envie de faire du
cinéma du cirque de propagande ce qu'on
constate en fait dans cette journée qui
vient de s'écouler aujourd'hui c'est
quand même voilà où on baisse d'un ton
de part et d'autre alors qu'est-ce que
ça augure en tout cas c'est plutôt
rassurant jusque on nous avait prédit
pour cette journée du 9 mai votre
documentaire hitler staline le choc des
tyrans c'est ce soir à 21h 10 hors de
paris sur france 3 merci à vous michaël
prazan merci thierry wolton merci adrien
deux ans à merci à vous donner à kataïev
merci bastien renouil heures direct de
kiev qui étaient avec nous pendant toute
l'émission et puis merci à karim akkari
l'achat bourg qui était à moscou merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis et vous
reste avec nous sans fin
[Musique]